so Capcom has a fairly sordid / rough
history with multiplayer Resident Evil's
trying again with projects resistance
what is it
should we be excited about it should we
actually pay attention to this one we
played it right yeah we did it's a new
montrezl knieval multiplayer game - for
v1 kind of deal like a symmetrical
multiplayer I think the probably thing -
like they want it to get across most is
it's very not early like it seems like
they've developed a bit of it but the
idea is being iterated on quite
significantly still they were like hey
we've been working on this for a while
we're experimenting with it we want to
kind of get it out there which is weird
because usually you wouldn't see that
but in an age where you know early
access is a thing they're a little more
empowered to do that so what we played
was rough but had the fundamentals of
what we want what they want to kind of
get out there and I don't know about you
but I kind of felt left for damage to me
well yeah totally I understand why you'd
feel that way because I mean the whole
deal is like you know the fourth so it's
for v1 and the four people four players
are just like survivors right each kind
of like like liver bled to have their
own sort of unique skills I said yeah
and the other side is it's like
basically what they call mastermind yeah
it's just like this dude was like it's a
cambria like it's like this is a good
umbrella like employee and whole
premises that he's trapped these four
survivors and I'm like an umbrella
facility facility and yeah so it's like
the masterminds job to try to thwart
them from escaping yeah so they they
were very cagey about the kind of what
the mastermind is so they're I think
they're trying to build a bit of
mystique around it and on the kind of
loading screen they had your picture of
the mastermind who's that his French guy
looks vaguely like Wesker with circle
circular black glasses and slicked back
and like a salt bay guy yeah but like
that kind of makes you think oh if
they've got a picture of the mastermind
there that means there's probably other
masterminds available and so like the
basics of it are like you said
asymmetrical for four characters four
survivors from different backgrounds you
get like a jock
a hacker type of biker girl and each of
them has this kind of like a special
skill and then an a fever skill which is
like the ultimate
yeah I was kind of hoping they'll go
fever it's just like no you're sick with
zombie voice and like each of them has
like everything's gonna cool down and
you're just going through this
environment that is like a testing
facility which seems to be like an
office type thing yeah yeah it means
divide the map that we played kind of
had that vibe to it but like it's like
sort of the large like area that you're
trying to escape from is like divided
into three areas yeah in each area has
like a unique objective that you have to
accomplish at least a set objective I
think yeah and it starts off quite
simple it's like just get to this point
in phase one and then once you've got
all your characters to that point it
advances you to the next phase or it's
like oh you need to find three keys and
use them on these terminals and then you
have to work together - or split apart
to do kind of like that element of it
and then you go into the final phase
where it's like oh you need to destroy
these canisters of t-virus or whatever
it may be and whatever virus biohazard
umbrella has been making you need to
destroy those canisters and then get to
it so along the way you find like
zombies are knocking about it feels like
they're going for like the hero type
thing the character hero archetypes like
you've got one which has got her a Oh F
healing you get another one who's got
basically got the Dudley's Rolling
Thunder attack from third strike where
it like he rushes them and you keep
hitting punch just punch yeah yeah it
just leaves you hunting but he's got
like another like overhead punch which
if you're being grabbed by a zombie if
you land that it breaks you away from
them and then you got cameras everywhere
so one of the hacker archetype you can
like hack the camera but like the
mastermind part of it seems to be the
unique part there right it's probably
the most entertaining part yeah honest
and that's where you excel yeah that
much but yeah it's that's a lot of fun
because it's interesting cuz the way it
works is that you know we played from
you put when you play the perspective of
mastermind you're looking through
cameras and you're just trying to
pinpoint the location of eat all the
survivors how far they're getting in
there all the while you have like a deck
of cards that you're kind of pulling
from and each one sort of represents
like here's it here's an it like like
enemies you can put onto the map and
even are somewhere like special
abilities like you can get
card that allows you to like use the
cameras a machine like put a machine gun
on a camera like shoot survivors former
Navy launcher oh yeah yeah
but the most fun sort of powerup that
you can use is mr. X yeah
you can literally spawn him on the map
and use him yeah and and he's gonna he's
unlike a timer basis yeah exactly you
can't really kill him each card is like
you said an enemy but like you can
choose where to place the enemy so like
you could do it like oh they're running
towards this exit I'm gonna put mr. X or
a licker there or I'm gonna put a trap
there and each time you do something
like for example like traps if you land
it and like they get hit by it it like
removes time that they've got to escape
so this is kind of like tug-of-war
between time where the survivors who
when they do something that aids their
survivor or helps each other
it adds time to it and when you do
something that makes it harder for them
successfully traps them wall gets one
killed down or something it removes time
for them so that's a kind of like added
layer but then like characters like mr.
X when you spawn them and they lived he
literally like just appears in front of
everything which is was kind of weird
yeah it's kind of weird because you you
know part the fun in Resident Evil 2 was
when he just came through a door yeah
but with this like everyone knows he's
coming because he's like appears you
could like spawn him around the corner
and then walk it yeah but it's a
strategy yeah but he's like for me I was
going for like I won't have the maximum
time with him so I put him right in me
from any of there's like buttons to give
him uses various attacks he's got like
an overhead punch he's got like a tackle
which grabs them at the end and like
kills them in Stickle yeah and now they
need to figure out how you kind of use
other people's for example when mr. X
goes for the insta kill you can use the
character with the overhead punch or the
kick to like save that person as mister
actually target that dude yeah I was
playing I was playing the kick guy who's
basically got a push kick which is too
powerful right now it could break a like
if and his zombie grabs you you can use
the kick to break free you can also like
just wait for a zombie to spawn and when
they stand up just kick him out of the
way and if you miss that actually can
use him to kick so I was doing that a
lot and then you were playing the
mastermind and you realized that I was
doing that
the moment you spawn him he just came
after me got me it's you I want
but like it's interesting because there
is like a back-and-forth between the
mastermind and the survivors as well
specifically that one character I think
her name's Valerie their bike ago or the
hacker god the heck so her like fever
skill was to increase the cost of the
masterminds cards so you're speaking of
which yeah cuz the whole thing is like
you know we're talking a lot about
putting enemies onto the map but the
whole things are very limited because
you have a sort of an energy bar so you
use consume certain amount of energy and
it replenishes yeah but it means that
like within a let's say turn you've got
a certain amount you can't just do like
mr. X liquor grenades like you've got a
certain amount that you need to think
about and you also need to think about
how you want to space out using it so
you've got time to for it to recover and
also you might not want to put all the
cards out right at the start because
then when they get to the end you'll
have nothing good to kind of slow them
down and there's like a bunch of
different other things that you can do
as the mastermind to make it a little
more interesting like you can hop
between cameras you always have the map
to see where everyone is so you could be
like oh this person seems to have like
split from the pack I'm gonna try and
separate them and like focus on them and
you can do things like turn the lights
off yeah so like if you place traps on
the floor and they turn the lights off
they all have trouble kind of figuring
out where to go can I just say like it
because of that stuff that's what makes
like masterminds so frickin fulfilling
because I just feel like a court like
it's evil genius like there were times
when like I'd turn the lights off but
not do anything else so like when the
lights came on they'd be like okay as it
wraps around so it's the the pace of
their natural players would naturally
slow down so they're looking for traps
because I've turned the lights off but
actually what I've done is just slowed
them down long enough for me to think
figure out what I need to what cards I
want to pick totally and that's the cool
thing because it's like all these tools
you have like it challenges you to think
in a way that like I think they were
saying like as like a Resident Evil
designer right you're kind of plotting
enemies you're using certain like
environmental effects to create like
like to impact the players in some way I
think like it seems like the foundation
of it feels good yeah like the idea is
there but there still it requires
fleshing out for example like we played
it once and then we replayed it and the
map sold immediately like I knew where
to go and you had to complete the
objectives it was
mixing up anything and as long as we
stuck together we were fairly we were
good with like taking out the enemies
you need to do things like collect
currency to buy stuff but and youthful
like that's why you want to stockpile
flashbangs for when mr. X appears you
can slow him down but each each of the
environments didn't really change yes we
asked about you and they said oh yeah
you should mix the things I'm gonna mix
up like items are gonna shuffle about
and stuff like that but it wasn't and
didn't seem that that was the case yes
even the map design itself too is a
little bit claustrophobic right there's
a lot of times especially because you're
just kind of clumped up together because
you don't to separate so like you know
and when enemy will come through and
then you're just trying to like kill the
one zombie yes I can't it was he it was
really weird because like left 4 dead
maps for example they're really smart in
that they have enough open areas for you
to be separated naturally but also for
whoever's you know the AI em controller
in the AI director in left 4 dead 2
separate you using enemies like it no
here's a big point like we can use the
witch hair or the blower hair to get rid
of you but because the maps are so
claustrophobic it works in that resident
evil claustrophobic style environment
but it means that almost everywhere you
go is a choke point which means which
means like if you're sticking together
you can just focus fire you you you and
there's never a way for you to unless
you slow down and that's how you get
separate generally you're sticking
together
maybe this it was just a case of like
this is a test map and we want to kind
of create an environment where the
action is to get a closer together but
right now I felt like I could easily win
or like I could understand exactly why I
need to do on a map to map basis yeah so
I really felt like you only just needed
like a few tries at it yeah or it starts
to become a little like you know you get
it like you you're confident in your
skills to just get through this and yeah
almost I'm sure after a while even
becomes tails
I feel like there needs to be more of
that Resident Evil puzzle element to it
like you know or two of you need to be
in this room while one of you is in this
room to try and kind of like solve you
know one of the weird pipe dreams the
whole puzzles to open a door something
like that so Capcom is making this with
a third-party developer it's the same
developer that worked on the HD remake
for Resident Evil 1 and 0 and I believe
the origins collection
and so yeah the remaster said I believe
this is their first original project
together and I feel like they've got the
foundation of something but I'm still
kind of cautious about it they've
they've got like we said in the start
like a weird history with morals and
evil I had enough fun there for me to
kind of be excited for what they might
be able to come up with this and I'm
gonna Bret I'm glad that they establish
its very early sort of conceptually
because it gives them sort of you know
grounds it's developed that and makes me
kind of excited to see like okay well
then they're very eager to hear about
what they can do to make an actual fun
Resident Evil multiplayer experience and
they're gonna have a beta but as far as
we know it's japan-only currently and we
were told that there would be
information about more open by an open
beta but like all welcoming people from
other territories into the beta but
we'll sit tight on that my biggest fear
is that they launch it as an early
access style unfinished thing there was
a time I know we talked about this on
the way out as well like there was a
time where you could do that but I think
and the pub G kind of like rode that
train but like these days I don't think
I'm hoping that Capcom is aware of the
fact that early access doesn't mean you
can polish or you can pull out something
that's really really early and rough and
then work on it but who knows we'll see
in the future yeah excited to see where
it goes yeah Sam
so when I don't Resident Evil baby
you